well i mean there's obviously good cause
to be concerned um we've only known
about this variant for uh just under two
weeks uh but the evidence is that it is
um becoming uh the dominant strain in
southern africa in the region
um it has a large number of mutated
changes from previous variants it's got
about 30 in the spike which is the key
that the virus uses to get into cells
and given that there's a lot we don't
know about it so we don't know for sure
what the
how much disease it causes you know has
other diseases we don't know the extent
to which it can evade the vaccines
although it's certainly likely that it
can at least impartivate the vaccines
for all those reasons it's important to
take precautions and we will learn more
quite rapidly
um
yeah the challenge is to hold it back
sorry
sorry
now i just wanted to say to you that you
know it was actually discovered in uh by
south african scientists doesn't mean
that that's where it originated but they
have said um that as far as they are
concerned it's only had very very mild
symptoms people that have have suffered
from this particular variant is that
because it is a younger population in
south africa or is it because we'll just
have to wait and see the impact of this
variant well it's likely to be both so
i'm sure it is a younger population and
we know that younger populations get
much milder disease um but we are going
to have to wait and learn more the
question is what happens in older people
can it to what extent can it evade the
vaccination and why it's why it's so
important for people to have the boosted
doses
so we have a lot to learn but as i say
it makes sense to try and hold it back
as lots of people have said it's going
to be impossible to stop it spreading
around the world if it is much more
infectious than the delta variant
how long will it take us to find out
more about it
well
um
we will need to see what happens when
people become infected not only um here
but around the world so we'll need to
learn from experience in other countries
um and we know that actually from
getting an infection it takes a couple
of weeks for the sort of most severe
manifestations to develop so i'm afraid
we do have to be a bit patient
um but we will learn very fast and of
course the other thing to say is that
the vaccine developers because of the
amazing new technology that we have for
the development of vaccines are already
preparing
um vaccines that should be able to boost
and cope with the new variant but that
will take about three months to develop
and so there are lots of reasons for
trying to as it were uh hold back the
the spread of the virus for as long as
we possibly can recognizing that we're
not going to have a
be able to do it forever
is this a yeah i was going to i was
going to want to ask you that very point
is this our new way of life now that
every time that scientists around the
world discover a new variant that we
have to
shut up shop until we discover whether
the vaccinations can work against them
look all pandemics eventually end and
they end essentially when the population
around the world becomes largely immune
but we know with influenza for example
that uh if we want to maintain immunity
that varies from year to year then we
need to have a booster vaccine every
year
um but at the moment we are still in the
pandemic itself
and uh the virus is still evolving so
uh uh sadly the uh omega and it's lucky
there are more letters in the greek
alphabet it's not going to be the last
of them i don't think okay um and as far
as the uk is concerned how did we close
our borders quick enough um on in in as
far as this south african variant is
concerned i mean we are an island we've
seen what australia has done we've seen
what new zealand have done they
basically shut up shop for a year or
more um have we been a little bit too
lacks with border control
well we are a global transport hub so i
mean the reality is that we are in a hot
spot for transport around the world
whereas australia and new zealand are by
virtue of their geography more isolated
um i think that you can't complain you
know given that this was only discovered
uh 10 days ago or so that action has
been taken pretty quickly in the uk and
indeed around the world
um but the important thing that we can
all do
and it's a sensible thing to do anyway
is firstly it's absolutely essential to
have the vaccination so we've still got
uh too many people in hospital um we've
got a quarter of our intensive care beds
occupied by people with coronavirus
of the of the intensive care beds that
are occupied and three quarters of those
are people are not fully vaccinated
so you know why are people taking that
unnecessary risk at the moment so people
should get vaccinated if they're
symptomatic they should stay at home and
get tested and
we really have a duty to each other to
protect people by wearing masks
and you know the issue about hospitality
is you know
saying you shouldn't wear a mask
uh you can and should wear a mask where
it's appropriate
in pubs and restaurants as well because
the government says no
well look if you are in a small poorly
ventilated enclosed space it makes sense
to wear a mask clearly when you are
drinking and eating it's not possible to
do that
but if you're moving around then
absolutely
because i specifically put that to the
minister and he said that they felt that
it wasn't necessary
well look we know that infection happens
in close places
indoors and of course as it gets colder
people are more likely to be indoors and
they're less likely to have the windows
open so
um if you're going to wear masks in
shops it makes sense to wear them in
other places as well so as i say
the question is what the legislation
demands and what common sense suggests
you should do
what about people who um are plant
they've already planned their christmas
holidays to go to europe go skiing
whatever spend time with family we can
see that the cases are increasing there
all the time should people stay at home
reconsider that
well i mean the point is that if you're
traveling from place a to place b and
the
frequency of the uh the the disease is
in the same in both places then you're
not increasing your risk by doing that
so i mean the issue really is to avoid
uh
transport moving from countries where
for example there's lots of omegran to
countries where there is a little but as
i say if you're going from country a to
b where the level of cases is much the
same then essentially you're not
increasing the risk either to yourself
or to the people that you're visiting
would you travel overseas this christmas
tomorrow
well i'm not planning to travel
over christmas i am going on a trip to
get a lecture in canada shortly
and we'll do all the tests and be very
careful